how did this reasonable mild-mannered
husband and wife
end up like this [ __ ] you Paulo to Bom
Bom this is a political I just want to
say real quick real quick
seriously Pat mm-hmm [ __ ] you something
they're calling the Patriots oath a
state-sponsored initiative to have
Americans sign a loyalty waiver to the
president the deadline for signing is
the day after Thanksgiving what is
happening in the country let's try to
avoid that conversation for the next
three days
if these [ __ ] bring up the oath
I'm gonna lose my mind
what did he do he lit a copy of the oath
on fire and where are you getting this
information from at fattest Patriots
okay he's a good source at fattest
Patriot he's verified he's a verified
[ __ ] idiot my brother I love him I bet
they signing the out like that you know
I'm a FEMINIST but his girlfriend is it
look you're not using that word in this
house you can use [ __ ] trash [ __ ] but
you cannot use that guy he's a trash
[ __ ] okay that's fine she's a trash
[ __ ]
I'm Peter Yoon for with the division of
Homeland Security we received a report
that you were impeding a private
citizens choice to sign the oath do you
guys have a warrant I just think the
three of us should go for a ride
[Music]
his head's all [ __ ] up thank you that
to his head over his head like that
before now it's time for practical
solutions okay house is gonna hit I
don't know I'm going to Mexico
maybe we become Mexican nationals I
speak a little bit of Spanish I will
learn more
[Music]
you